ladies gentlemen and tobacco product
enjoyers of all types Riot has just
banned players from using snooze on
stage if you don't know any of the words
that just came out of my mouth prepare
to learn
[Music]
snooze and its synthetic counterparts
like Zinn are a form of tobacco products
that work basically the same as chewing
tobacco you put it behind your lip
ingest the nicotine and Bob's your uncle
now if you're from North America and
have ever played hockey or baseball
snooze isn't that big of a deal sure
it's super bad for you but it's
everywhere and that's doubly true if
you're European I'm serious you can't
swing a dead cat without hitting a
Scandinavian who packs a lip or two in a
2018 report over 20 percent of question
Danes admit to using snooze daily by the
looks of it it's only becoming more
popular especially amongst younger
people and on top of the cultural
reasons for its usage the popularity of
the product can be basically boiled down
to the fact that it's discreet and
odorless compared to cigarettes it's
also hands-free which means that you can
multitask pretty much whatever you want
whether it's crushing bombs to center
field or even playing Counter-Strike
just you know an AK Kevlar and then oh
lovely yeah yes thanks to CS being
infested with swedes and Danes players
using products like this on stage has
become something of a staple for the
esport now since broadcasters obviously
don't want to promote the use of tobacco
to the potential kids watching they
usually done their best to try and cut
away when it's on camera however Riot
games just took it one massive step
further by outright Banning snooze from
the VCT
sort of technically speaking all tobacco
products are banned from the match area
and have been for quite some time that
being said my suspicion is that since
noose is discreet and so culturally
relevant to certain areas of the world
players were mostly getting away with it
but this all changed last week when Navi
was hit with a loss of a timeout during
their match against DRX after Angel was
caught using snooze on stage and
apparently this penalty was handed down
immediately it was [__] angel
with two fingers too
finger Angel got them [__] penalized
now in the wake of this whole snooze
gate the community mostly memed about it
but some had some legitimate questions
as to why why does Riot care if it's not
affecting anyone well the answer is
likely the simple one I mentioned
earlier and it could be the same reason
as to why they don't allow gambling
sponsors
kids watch Esports Riot clearly cares
about running a clean ship and rampant
snooze use or vaping looking at you
Potter doesn't paint the best picture
now you can argue that Red Bull a
massive Esports sponsor is just as bad
for kids as snooses and sure maybe I can
agree with you on certain occasions but
the stigma just isn't there Plus or I
can just do whatever the [__] I want to
be honest with you but regardless if you
even agree with the penalty that Navi
received this isn't even the first time
that weird has been banned from
professional play back in 2016 ESL
famously banned hats from being worn on
stage and more recently they also banned
open-toed Footwear and non-team related
attire although the community has long
questioned these clothing related bands
many suspect it's been in an effort to
professionalize the sport to be fair not
being able to wear Crocs on stage is
pretty inconsequential in the grand
scheme of things and I would argue that
since nicotine is an addictive substance
cracking down on snooze is a much bigger
deal with that said let me pass it off
to you guys do you think this is a fair
ruling or do you think that players
should be able to snooze to their hearts
content and more broadly speaking if it
doesn't affect competitive Integrity or
any sponsor deals do you think to should
have any say on what players can do on
stage let me know
they'll always try to put weird [__] out
but I saw one the other day when I was
going through valorence competitive
rulings
and uh
you're not allowed to bring even like a
piece of paper with you if you're a
player but if you're the coach you can
bring whatever the [__] you want
which I thought was weird because it's
just like
it isn't like what are you gonna have on
a piece of paper